[Musique]
ça fait deux ans que je n'ai pas acheté
un seul vêtement neuf c'est à dire que
depuis deux ans l'industrie de la mode
aurait pu s'arrêter de produire des
vêtements je ne l'aurais pas remarqué
j'ai créé une entreprise qui permet de
bien s'habiller tout en réduisant le
gaspillage textile alors la première
fois que j'ai entendu parler de l'impact
social et environnemental des
entreprises j'étais au lycée et
j'écoutais la fondatrice d'une marque de
cosmétiques qui a exprimé sa vision de
l'entrepreneuriat
elle disait qu'il ne s'agissait pas
seulement d'une question d'avidité
personnel ou d'argent mais d'une
question de responsabilité et de bien
commun alors j'ai compris aussi après
coup que c'était la première fois que je
me faisais avoir par le greenwashing
mais peu importe à l'époque ça m'a
permis de me poser la question de la
place que je voulais occupé dans la
société
j'étais désormais convaincu que les
consommateurs comme les entreprises
avaient un pouvoir fort pour construire
un monde plus responsable et en fait
l'entrepreneuriat mme apparaissait déjà
comme une opportunité inédite pour
façonner ce monde de manière plus juste
alors avec le recul c'est pas non plus
absurde que ces paroles et fait écho en
moi parce que j'avais été sensibilisés à
l'écologie bien plus jeunes dès la
maternelle en fait puisque la maîtresse
avait installé dans la cour de l'école
un compost ou pouvait ramener son sachet
de thé de la maison pour alimenter le
compost et je crois que c'est à partir
de ce jour là où j'ai commencé à
poursuivre tout le monde pour le moins
de s'agiter qui partait accidentellement
à la poubelle et puis ma mère aussi qui
est médecin nous avait vraiment
sensibilisés à l'impact de
l'alimentation sur la santé et donc elle
a acheté exclusivement des produits bio
alors c'est sûr qu'à l'époque c'était un
peu marginale et c'était moins marrant
quand dans la cour de l'école les les
autres enfants sortaient leur kinder et
moi j'étais là avec mes amendes et mes
raisins secs mais en même temps c'était
un peu visionnaire
quand on voit qu'il ya des jours d'hui
des rayons bio dans absolument tous les
supermarchés et donc j'étais au lycée et
je m'intéressais déjà à la mode
j'avais fait un stage pour une grande
marque mais j'étais revenu avec un
sentiment un peu mitigé
d'un côté on m'avait vendu du rêve mais
de l'autre on m'avait tellement parler
business que je me disais mais comment
je vais bien pouvoir m'épanouir dans une
industrie qui ne vend finale
que l'illusion d'un monde meilleur et
donc j'ai réfléchi je me suis dit je
fais attention à ce que je mange à ce
que je jette
pourquoi est ce que je pourrais pas
faire attention à ce que je porte et en
fait d'un en approfondissant un peu
cette question je me suis rendu compte
que le manque de transparence des
marques cacher une réalité vraiment
sombre en fait derrière la production de
nos vêtements
il y a des couturiers ou plutôt des
ouvriers textiles qui sont payés des
salaires de misère
les usines sont parfois tellement
délabrée qu'elle en vienne à s'effondrer
et puis avec la crise du coc vie de 19
on a bien vu que les marques
occidentales ont tellement de pouvoir
elles peuvent mettre la pression sur
leurs sous traitants a décidé du jour au
lendemain de ne plus les payer
alors je parlais des ouvriers textiles
mais en fait 80 % sont des ouvrières qui
peuvent être victimes quotidiennement
sur leur lieu de travail de harcèlement
moral et sexuel
et puis ben on a aussi découvert que
certaines enseignes très connu se
fournissent dans des camps ouigours et
puis à cela il faut ajouter l'empreinte
environnementale de l'industrie de la
mode puisque c'est une des industries
les plus polluantes
donc si on prend un jean par exemple bas
pour produire un seul jean il faut onze
mille litres d'eau c'est comme si vous
preniez 285 douche et puis si on
recommande de laver son usine avant de
le porter c'est parce qu'en fait il a
encore empreint de produits toxiques qui
bat à côté des usines de production vont
aller colorer les fleuves contaminé des
habitants autour des usines et puis
ensuite bas il y a l'empreinte carbone
alors si on prend un d'une made in
tunisie par exemple ça paraît très
simple et relativement proche de nous
mais en fait le coton il va pousser en
inde
il va être tissés au pakistan puis temps
en chine et il va effectivement être
assemblés en tunisie mais avec des rides
australien des fermetures éclair du
japon des boutons de la rdc
et finalement ce jean il aura fait une
fois et demi le tour de la terre avant
d'arriver tu as un rayon et puis ensuite
il sera achetée par des occidentaux
finalement ignorants comme je l'étais
loin des yeux loin du coeur alors j'ai
essayé de réfléchir à ce que ça
représentait pour moi de faire du
shopping et je me suis dit bah c'était
d'abord une façon de m'exprimer c'est
vrai et puis de passer un bon moment un
moment de complicité avec mes proches
mais qui nous rendait malgré tout
complice de l'exploitation humaine et du
désastre écologique alors vous allez me
dire aujourd'hui les marques
éco-responsable fleurissent et tant
mieux mais le problème c'est que le
discours marketing est toujours le même
pousser à la consommation et ses marais
bien malgré tout leur engagement elle
passe à côté du problème systémique de
l'industrie de la mode celui du
gaspillage textile plus de 100 milliards
de vêtements sont produits chaque année
alors que si on s'arrêtait maintenant de
produire
ben on pourrait veiller encore les cinq
prochaines générations mais j'ai pris
conscience de ça je me suis mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'on se laisse
entraîner dans ce système
pourquoi est-ce qu'on accepte qu'on nous
vante du prête à jeter et qu'on nous
pousse à racheter davantage
en fait je crois que c'est le manque de
sens que l'on met dans nos achats
alors c'est vrai qu'on est mal influencé
par les marques qui veulent nous faire
croire que c'est normal d'acheter un
t-shirt à 4 euros 99
mais quelqu'un en paye le prix et donc
c'est finalement ce manque de recul sur
l'impact de nos achats qui va entretenir
ce gaspillage permanent on achète on
jette dans le pire des cas et au mieux
on accumule alors bas quand j'étais
enfant j'adorais piquer des vêtements à
mes parents et à mes proches et je leur
demandais toujours de les garder pour
pour moi quand je serai grande et il ya
peu près trois ans je me suis rendu
compte que ça y est j'ai été grande et
que pas finalement j'avais tous ses
vêtements dans mon placard qui s'étaient
accumulés parce que ces événements je ne
l'aimé pas elle ne donne pas jeûner
jette surtout pas et pourquoi pas parce
que j'y suis attaché parce que en fait
ça fait des années que je garde ses
trésors disant que je pourrai un jour
les remettre à ma taille
les retravailler pour qu'ils soient à
nouveau à la mode et donc j'avais des
tas d'idées mais pas les compétences
pour passer à l'action
mais je me suis rendu compte qu'elle
était là finalement la ressource textile
la plus écoresponsable près des yeux et
près duquel a alors c'est après tout les
réflexions que j'en partage et que j'ai
eu l'idée de créer une marque qui
permettent de faire transformer ses
vêtements à partir d'un patron sur
mesure donc le concept c'est de choisir
parmi un catalogue de patrons qui a été
conçu spécialement pour transformer une
pièce en une nouvelle pièce et ensuite
on va être mis en relation avec un
couturier partenaires qui lui bah va
adapter le patron parfaitement à notre
morphologie
dès que j'ai eu cette idée ça a été
vraiment un déclic dans mon envie
d'entreprendre et de m'engager pour une
mode plus responsables comme jean
souhaitait en fait depuis longtemps
alors en 2019
ça faisait déjà un an après ce que
j'avais cette idée j'étais encore à la
fin de mes études mais j'avais envie de
concrétiser les idées que j'avais donc
j'ai appris à coudre un peu tout seul
les commencé à transformer mes vêtements
et puis alors rapidement cette
compétence en couture ça m'a permis de
mieux comprendre toutes les questions
techniques liées à la création d'un
vêtement et puis ben rapidement beaucoup
de mes premiers prototypes
aujourd'hui je travaille avec un
styliste et plusieurs couturiers et je
viens de lancer mon site internet ainsi
que ma marque renaissance est cycling
donc le service qui permet de faire
transformer ses vêtements à partir d'un
patron sur mesure alors je viens de
prononcer le mot axa it clean
qu'est ce que c'est en fait c'est le
fait de revaloriser un matériau existant
en augmentant sa valeur donc dans mon
cas le fait de prendre un vêtement on ne
met plus pour être considéré comme un
déchet et puis donner une seconde vie
alors le mot il est récent il est
peut-être peu connu mais le concept puis
il a rien de nouveau
j'ai retrouvé dans le grenier de ma
grand-mère des costumes de la marine de
mon grand père qui avait été
prédécoupés décousu tout près pour être
utilisés refaire des vêtements pour ses
enfants dedans
donc en fait j'ai trouvé ça incroyable à
quel point la récupération à l'époque
c'était juste du bon sens on savait en
fait que le texte était une ressource
cher est précieuse et on avait
conscience du travail que représente la
confection d'un vêtement alors
l'objectif de renaissance est cycling à
terme c'est de proposer des solutions
pour transcende tous les vêtements qu'on
met plus et on a décidé de commencer par
les pantalons donc on a créé dix patrons
pour faire transformer un pantalon en
bas une jupe une robe salopette un sac
est d'ailleurs ballard que je porte
aujourd'hui c'était un pantalon beige
pour la petite histoire c'était à ma
soeur mais elle ne mettait en vacances
l'été il ya peut-être 20 ans et
maintenant il est une ville sous la
forme de drogue et on a encore plein
d'idées ben parce que l'obstacle
en fait c'est une source infinie de
créativité le fait de partir d'une pièce
existante avec une quantité de textile
limité ça pousse en fait à inventer des
pièces qu'on aurait peut-être pas
imaginer autrement tard est un domaine
où tout est inventé
et donc c'est pour ça que les métiers
créatifs sont au coeur de notre service
donc le styliste par exemple lui il doit
concevoir un patron qui s'adapte avec la
ddt comme cité textile limité et il doit
revaloriser au maximum la matière
première
donc par exemple pour que j'aie une jupe
à partir d'un pantalon marron va
reprendre le bouton la fermeture éclair
et puis ensuite il ya le couturier qui
lui va accueillir le client et lui
confectionner une pièce vraiment sur
mesure et donc l'objectif de ce service
c'est justement de remettre en valeur
ces métiers qui sont devenus
complètement invisible dans l'industrie
de la mode
et comme en bas tout simplement en
proposant une expérience qui est inédite
aujourd'hui dans la mode puisque le
réflexe pour renouveler son dressing ça
va plus être d'aller faire du shopping
mais ça va être de se dire qu'est ce que
j'ai déjà dans mon placard et que je
pourrai revaloriser et donc on va
pouvoir se laisser inspirer par nos
propositions de transformation
et puis ensuite allé rencontrer
l'artisan qui va créer des vêtements et
donc non seulement on va recréer du lien
mais en plus on va reprendre conscience
de la manière dont on fait nos vêtements
et donc c'est cette proximité qui va
garantir la transparence
on sait exactement parti et comment nos
vêtements sont fabriqués alors je vous
le disais au début ça fait deux ans que
je n'ai pas acheté un seul vêtement neuf
donc tout simplement je transforme et
vêtements j'achète parfois de la seconde
main ou alors j'ai changé des vêtements
avec mes proches et ça me rend
véritablement plus heureuse parce que
ben en fait en achetant moins je me
rends compte de la valeur de ce que j'ai
déjà
je suis plus en accord avec mes
convictions et je peux trouver de belles
pièces responsable facilement et puis
c'est un cercle vertueux parce qu'en
fait en donnant une seconde vie à ces
pièces donc je prolonge histoire mais ça
me donne envie d'en prendre soin et
créer des looks intemporel donc c'est
une démarche globale de durabilité
alors vous l'aurez compris je suis
convaincu que l'obstacle y est une
alternative vertueuse à l'achat de
vêtements neufs
parce qu'il remet en lumière les métiers
créatifs il réduit considérablement le
gaspillage textile et il redonne du sens
à notre expérience de la mode
alors j'espère vous avoir donné envie de
changer vos habitudes
et puis bah après avoir passé ces
quelques minutes avec vous à refaire le
monde
je vous invite à commencer par refaire
vos vêtements
[Applaudissements]